it's happening hi guys manners for
something you do not know your life is
different now look it's here it's Molly
Byrd she just transplanted to Los
Angeles from the lovely Toronto Canada
and I'm so happy that you're here
literally were in your time I am ever
filming in this apartment and you are
here with me to do it yeah we have a
really fun challenge today we are going
to be decorating cakes wine I mean
you're gonna be doing that anyway I
never ate every cake blind you when I
celebrate every cake blind
I don't decorate so it really even
though I'm blind and live every day
without night it's still going to be a
challenge for me I have sight and this
is going to be bad I've actually done
this one time before with my friend
Mitchell and it did not go very well
okay well my hand is in the stud are we
not supposed to okay and I didn't
realize that that could be an option I'm
just trying to get it was nice enough on
the she's got a lot of her skins bad you
only have to cover the top of the cake
we don't do the side wait just the top
oh it's just the top then you know where
am I check me
[Music]
[Music]
cheeks cheeks down here I got here and
Molly and her mom had already made these
funfetti cakes for us to decorate so you
guys have already gone above and beyond
we have a bunch of different cake
decorating apparatus here's only option
and not only do they make cakes they
made fun okay always the fun setting I
feel like the icing is honestly gonna be
the most struggle and well we have
knives that's good okay what have we
decorated cake for each other Oh cuz
we're sweet and then we eat them oh yeah
that's my favorite part as game this is
just all a big ruse to get the cake
eating part of it I say let's do like
five minutes
I think it's gonna take me five minutes
just to ice this and I'm gonna put the
blindfold on myself as well just so that
nobody can be like she's sighted right
she cheated there's all these conspiracy
theories out there that's really big
Molly excited and which is mine
hilarious oh thank you Delta Delta
flight remind us with lightful oh my god
not advertised not spawn
but I mean reach out built up we're open
to it
we're open these okay and there is a
napkin if you need it I feel like hands
are gonna be really involved I said
hands are utensil right I hope you wash
your hands because I'm not eating that
cake you got my Murray side yes oh I
love with the spoon oh and it's gonna
devolve into hands immediately I'm sorry
that I'm gonna destroy your kitchen
Nilay eautiful did a nice like clean
brand-new carpets they played below me
oh yeah okay I feel like my cake is
really becoming beautiful I'm good
you're confident in your yeah I don't
have much of it at this moment if
anything my hands have gone through a
makeover
okay I'm not bothering icing the edges
anyway got time for that we have so many
options for decorations which is great
oh I had a plan
for what I wanted the edges to look like
and it's gone awry already I want to say
how to plan but I didn't my hands are so
I think this is happening I have some
concepts in my mind but I have a feeling
it's not translating correctly let's see
where our other treats haha yeah gummi
bears were an option I'm not sure why
breaking my brand-new ball haha you know
I'm left-handed which is what you
biggest issue here but my left
handedness is implied a left-handed okay
I feel like my cake is coming to an end
in terms of its decorating decoration
I'm almost done I'm just gonna attempt
to write Oh goblin which is going to be
the real downfall I know that mine has
not gone the way that I would have
wanted it to but art is not for
interpretation it smells amazing in here
by the way it smells like a lot of fun
bye oh oh I'm gonna say my fingers are
sticky enough yeah and I
that I'm done okay I'm gonna say I'm
done - who the reveal
Wow Wow yours is so pretty it's supposed
to say smile I don't know if it wrote
anything um it definitely doesn't say
anything you can see the attempt to
write smile okay but there is a dog hair
in it that really is the epitome of my
life I have a guide dog his name is
galih
he's like this big black dog everywhere
I go he stands on my left side guiding
me all the time I just have hair all
over - I don't wear black pants every
day now my aesthetic
well and speaking of Galip my cake is a
tribute to gallop it was supposed to be
a dog shape on here but it's kind of
like a Rorschach what did you make but
all shape out of every candy I could get
my grubby hands off already to try and
draw it with some cake icing but I felt
like that wasn't going well so I tried
to make a dog shape with all of the
candy it looks kind of like a bug did
you just kind of like throw them on and
then try to mold it yeah out of the
technique yeah it looks a little bit
like a butterfly a little bit like a
crude penis maybe a little bit like the
letter I kind of it's not good well here
I have a smiley face cuz you make
everybody smile and then you have such a
colorful personality so we did the
colors yeah you really enjoyed it yours
looks like it's actually really well
done and then it was supposed to say
smile that was gonna be like the
finishing touch it's the thought that
counts give us some comments down below
which cake did you love which cake did
you hate you guys gonna tell us all the
things wait do you anyway don't they're
probably gonna be like I'm not gonna eat
either of them because they're nasty
yeah and they're all oh yeah I'd only
pick out for like 10 minutes when I got
here and then just put my hands in icing
and put it on a cake so this was really
fun I feel a domestic AF like a domestic
I feel like a housewife you guys haven't
already go check out Molly's channel
we're doing another thing I'm terrible
at is identifying
odors over on her channel so go check
them out the link will be in description
box below but go check out all of my
teeth
Molly's videos super sweet really funny
and just an overall breath of fresh air
oh thank you thank you um we'll see you
guys next time
I don't know ah you barely have any ice
cream on your hands um I used the napkin
that we provided oh no I'm just a trash
monster I went full out I I utilized
this to its fullest potential yeah I'm
like what's a napkin what does that do I
don't know